what happened but it was a yes a great
it's a great moment and a win that we
needed over two years since your last
goal so this must be feeling very very
special particularly after last week as
well yeah yeah it's been too long I
can't remember the last time I saw
reports of your knees
Manchester City have kept the pressure
on Premier League leaders Liverpool with
a win at Huddersfield they won three nil
at the John Smith Stadium fullback
DeLillo's deflected strike opening the
scoring after 18 minutes nine minutes
into the second half it was 2 nil
Leroy Sunday's cross headed in by Raheem
Sterling the flag staying down and two
minutes later they got their third man
of the match Saleh completing the
scoring and means City returned to
within four points of leaders Liverpool
with 15 games to go a right they would
prefer to in the Louisville position I
know we can do in our games so what
should I say so so was wean our game so
improve so now have to do analyze what
we had done in our game so to improve
former Manchester United midfielder Paul
sculls has held talks about becoming the
new manager of League Two side Oldham we
understand that he's the front-runner to
take over from interim boss Pete wild
Oldham are expected to decide on a new
manager tomorrow sculls miss out on
becoming their boss 15 months ago hearts
have drawn semi-pro side or can elect
Tolbert in the fifth round of the
Scottish FA Cup hearts got there by
beating Livingston 1 nil today Steven
Naismith laying the ball off for Shawn
Claire to score holders Celtic fakes and
Johnston Rangers visit come on ik and
Inverness travelled to Ross County now
there's been a major shock at the
Australian Open where defending men's
champion Roger Federer is out he was
beaten by stefanos sits a pass in the
fourth round this six-time champion
serving his saved three set points to
win the opening set on a tie-break
he'd only lost twice in 89 matches in
Melbourne
in the first set the however the second
set also went the distance to young
Greek 14 seeds saving for set points
before winning another tie break at
level the match since mas took the third
set 75 and before the fourth set went to
yet another tie break Federer would not
give up but the twenty-year-old held his
nerve he saw out the tiebreak to claim
the biggest win of his career and
reached his first Grand Slam
quarter-final he'll play Andy Murray's
Conqueror roberto's was bout to start
with least next the world number 2
Rafael Nadal in the orange here is
through to the last 8 he the 17 time
Grand Slam champion people Thomas
verdicts in three sets to reach his 37th
Grand Slam quarter-final Wimbledon
champion Angelique Kerber has been
knocked out by world number 35 Daniel
Collins the world number 2 at the top of
your screen was beaten six love six - in
a match lasting only 56 minutes
Collins will play Anastasia
Pavlyuchenkova
in the quarterfinals and she beat Sloane
Stephens hometown favorite Ashleigh
Barty at the top of your screen is
through to the quarterfinals of a major
for the first time in her career the 22
year old came from a set down to beat
former champion Maria Sharapova 4-6 6-1
6-4 and she'll play yet to give it for
their next Leinster have got themselves
a home quarter-final against ole stone
rugby's european champions cup defending
champions won by 37 points to 19 against
wasps to make sure of a home last 8
match scary ring roads got their open
trying Leicester work 20 nil ahead when
wasps got their first points England
number 8
Nathan Hughes they're crashing over the
Irish side extended their lead again
though when Shawn Cronin got his second
try the afternoon he was in the middle
of this driving more wasps unable to
stop the lens to forwards from going
over we just have to take our word for
that one
wasps got two more tries thanks to Dan
Robson and Marcus Watson but lens to
seal their bonus point win with the
strive the game no read finishing off
that move they win cool one with five
wins out of six French side two loser
also has the quarterfinals is one of the
best runners-up they held on to beat
fast 2017 and 20-point capitalizing on a
loose ball to put Toulouse 17:3 up
before half-time sabar fought back in
the second half this time the loose ball
bounce their way so mr. Rochard didn't
move me scoring into the side and when
Zach Mercer score with five minutes to
go the lead was only three points but
it's lose held on towards the last eight
and they will play racing 90 to 40 year
old boxer Manny Pacquiao continues to
roll back the years he be Adrien Broner
a man 11 years his junior to retain his
welterweight world title in Las Vegas
Pacquiao won by a unanimous decision
keeping the WBA belt in his 70th
professional fight a big year for
England's cricketers starts on Wednesday
2019 brings a home Ashes series and a
home World Cup but bowler James Anderson
is fully focused on the tour of the West
Indies at all that brings back some fond
memories we've not won a series since
then but for me being that going past
the beef his record in Antigua was a
really special week
[Applause]
that's what Jimmy Anderson has been
waiting for he now becomes England's
leading wicket-taker
of all time in Test matches never set
myself goals that literally just try and
get myself fit and prepared for it for
the next game I feel like if I look too
far ahead and I sort of take my focus
off what I need to be doing now you know
is a huge if it was World Cup and ashes
in England which is going to be huge but
I think that's something that we would
rather focus on when that time comes
rather than taking our focus off what is
an important tour here by the end of
tonight we'll know which two teams will
appear in this year's NFL showpiece the
Super Bowl both Conference Finals are
live on Sky Sports USA later and Kansas
versus New England Patriots could be a
thriller and a chiller these were the
scenes last week before a recent cold
snap temperatures for the AFC
Championship game could be as low as
minus 20 Celsius the coldest NFL game
was in 1967 though the Green Bay Packers
played the Dallas Cowboys in minus 25
that was said to have gone to minus 40
with windchill there's more Premier
League reaction now on Sky Sports News
we're back with sports line at 8:30 for
Life Insurance that rewards healthy
living vitality
well time now to have a look at the
weather by the springtime flowers of a
mountain lake - the first snowfall on a
winter's day
[Music]
southeastern parts find tomorrow but
strong winds rain and hill snow will
move across the north and the west
before that is going to be mainly dry
this evening but Central Britain will
see a little bit of rain there'll be a
few coastal showers to Wales and central
England we'll see some patchy drizzle
and Hill fog tonight but cloudy skies
will keep it largely frost-free
elsewhere most places will be dry with
long clear spells leading to a patchy
frost but northwest Scotland will see
some blustery showers so when to be
mainly dry on Monday morning but fairly
cloudy to with a scattering of showers
near northern coasts or general rain and
strong winds in the northwest the
weather sponsored by Qatar Airways stay
with us after the break here on sky news
it's brexit Deal or No Deal we will be
live in Leeds for our special program do
stay with us to hear the views of a city
that was hugely divided over the
referendum back in 2016
[Music]
[Music]
good evening and welcome to Leeds
University to the pyramid canteen for a
special programme looking at possible
ways forward for brexit tomorrow Theresa
May will take her plan B to the houses
of parliament but this here tonight
mercifully is a politician free zone we
have some good people from this region
who can come up with some ideas and
suggestions
we're in Leeds because in the 2016
referendum is one of the most evenly
split cities in the UK and tonight we're
going to be discussing the issues with
local people half of whom voted remain
half of whom voted to leave a big
variety of Ages jobs we're also going to
be conducting a series of votes among
the audience and comparing them with a
national poll carried out by Sky News
let's see if we can come up with any
ideas to send to Westminster
it's Briggs it crisis Deal or No Deal
[Applause]
[Music]
but before we get going let's assess how
this city has dealt with the ongoing
paralysis bedeviled our exit from the EU
skies north of England correspondent
gerald tom has been out and about the
start of a new day in leaves a city
split 50-50 in the referendum
collectively unsure if brexit would be a
new dawn or a harsh awakening
Leeds is a city of wealth with a 21
billion pound economy it has 10,000
people working in digital companies it's
also a city of disadvantage with almost
1 in 3 of its school children living in
some of the most deprived areas of the
country in one of them a delivery of
Italian tiles is being unloaded this
firm spends a million pounds a year on
European imports and employs 18 people
one of them told me she wants a second
referendum and thinks this time more
people would vote remain what do you
worry about if we do leave now
well jobs mainly jobs income have to not
be affected trade wise and obviously
living standards food you know
everything's gonna be affected
especially for obviously ordinary
working people so it's just a sister
worry overall there's less of a sense of
worry in this busy city centre Hair
Studio a cut and blow-dry here is 34
pounds but they despair that there's
nothing cut and dried about brexit you
think what when you think of brexit I
think confusion and I think that the
public were misled I think parity is 31
married to an IT worker with a toddler's
future to think of she doesn't want
another referendum but if there is one
she'll vote I think I would have to do
some research I don't feel like you're a
waiver yes at the moment
the salons co-owner meanwhile is just
baffled I really don't understand it and
I feel extremely sorry for charissa may
I really really do she thinks we should
just get on with the decision tonight
but if there were a second referendum I
feel I would still vote the same way but
I'm very worried about the backlash
that's gone on so that makes me think so
you're just confused really I'm
extremely confused back at tiles and
mosaics they feel their European
suppliers will work with them to keep
their business but the remainders here
are as baffled as the levers about what
happens next as a business we are
prepared to happy to move on and
positive about moving on but to what we
don't know and the most worrying thing
is the politicians don't seem to know
either so what do we do
brexit will be the end of a chapter for
good or ill two and a half years after
the referendum people here seem to be
less certain than ever which it will be
jarred tub Sky News leads
well also tonight we have a brexit
expert in the house a break spurt if you
like this is Professor and on men on now
he's a professor at King's College of
European politics and he's also a
director of UK in a changing Europe now
the whole point of being here is if
anyone has any factual questions isn't
it so someone wants to know what WTO
rules are or what the backstop is you're
gonna be able to help us I'm very glad
we've got you here so let's bring in our
first topic and it's the question we'll
be asking our audience in a few minutes
and the question is should the UK leave
the European Union at the end of March
without a deal that's the so-called No
Deal scenario let's move over to this
side of the room first of all let's talk
to Stephen Stephen you're the director
of an import business and you voted
leave but it could affect your company
are you still happy that you voted and
you're still thinking that a No Deal is
the right thing I suppose what you're
really asking is almost a sociological
problem but I think it reflects
something much deeper than that and I
think it reflects the crisis that's been
created by the political class they fail
to understand they're ordinary people
and I cast myself as one of those
ordinary people can take the step beyond
narrow selfish economic things that yes
affect all our lives but can look to a
bigger purpose most people did that when
they voted in the referendum and the
political class I do hope the listening
they need to understand that this is
such an important situation we are
capable of looking at bigger issues and
the issues for me and not about me me me
my business my business negatively it
will affect my family as far family
members was built it overturns years we
import it completely from the EU but
there's more important issues and it's
not just about me it's about sovereignty
and democracy and it's the last word
that is the real issue now we've got a
political class
they are refusing to listen to a
Democratic majority Orion vote the vote
was taken we instructed them they should
obey our wishes because they don't we
haven't got an economic crisis we
haven't got a political crisis we've got
a democratic crisis in this country
and that should concern not just me as a
leader it should concern those that
abstained it should concern all
remainders because if we don't have in
this country majoritarian democracy we
must all of us ask ourselves what do we
have you're sitting behind Stephen from
the opposite camp you're a remainer you
know he this is a man behind you who
could be affected very economically
about his decision but he still had the
guts to go ahead and vote the way he
chose we're putting your concerns about
the economic impact I'm concerned about
and No Deal raise it
I think from what's coming across in the
press that we that we could have a
fairly dramatic downturn in the economy
and I don't think that would be good for
jobs and for people at large however I
do agree with C in that I do think that
we've voted to leave and I think we do
need to be very careful about how we
respond to that that Monday that the
government and their people have given
so as a remain oh you're happy to
respect the referendum result I'm happy
to respect it I would prefer not to be
respecting it I would prefer to stay in
but yes I would I would I would actually
say respect it I think one of the things
that the government I think need to do
when politicians need
in particular is they need to look at
the different scenarios in terms of how
we do a brexit
well the whole point of this first first
section of this program is asking that
question what if we go for a No Deal
crashed out as some people have
described it Matt next to you you're a
lorry driver how would a No Deal affect
you your job your family I work quite
quite close to the construction industry
and a lot of the projects are funded by
huge subsidies and that kind of thing so
obviously from a purely selfish point of
view if the work dries up there then
it's gonna affect me and my family
standard of living as well products on
the shelves being more expensive Hey
yeah there's an and you your you've also
got family in Europe haven't you we have
yes what impact do you think it could
have there do you fear well we they are
part of the expatriate community so they
wouldn't have to pay actually terrorists
to come back and visit the country that
they're actually from I don't think
that's right it's also okay let's move
on to the next table that there was a
thoughts of over couple of remainders at
Craig over here Matt their lorry driver
talking about the construction industry
you're actually a joiner and what impact
are you finding and are you still happy
that if we went out on a no deal I saw
that happen because out on audio I think
there's just been so scamming grit in
everything that's being said end of the
day nobody's like any idea of what's
going to happen the main thing that's
been brought up I feel well I think a
lot of people in this room do is that
this is no longer a debate about leave
stare referendum this is a debate about
democracy we voted to leave if it
doesn't happen
we have no democracy but the question in
this part is what if it is a No Deal I
mean I know you wanted to happen but if
it was No Deal if it was extending the
deal the different options they're out
there you'd be happy with No Deal you'd
go with it definitely happy with audio
okay let's let's move over to this side
of the room let's talk to Natalie and
Natalie what are your feelings about No
Deal well I'm terrified about the idea
of a No Deal I think it's the worst
possible thing that could happen I we
heard we heard sorry but I'm just there
about scaremongering I mean do you think
you have been swayed by by some of the
fearful stories you've heard well even
the only economists that actually thinks
that brexit is a good idea
says that it will destroy our color
industry if we have an Odile brexit so
how is that a good thing all those jobs
are going to go that's not project fear
that is project facts and I think
unfortunately what's happened with this
debate is somebody said that there's
don't have experts but we do need to
listen to people that have studied and
know what actually is going to happen I
mean the Bank of England were derided
for for saying that they had scenarios
but they actually worked to make sure
that after we had the referendum result
that the economy didn't go down so I do
think that we do need to listen to
experts and that we do need to accept
that
trading on WTO rules which no other
country in the world trades on just WTO
rules is a disaster and we need to do
everything we can to avoid that well you
were sitting next to it an MD or expert
just give us a basic price you very
briefly what are WTO rules
well WTO is the global trading
organizations 160 old states remember of
it and it set some basic bottom lines
for trade tries to free up global trade
set minimum standards the point is right
that there is no major country that
trades entirely on delito rules no BTO
rules let you go and sign trade deals
with your closest partners Brit sir it's
a baseline if you like that don't you
and economically what Natalie was saying
there about about none of the experts
saying that it's gonna be an economic
good dinner and you want one economist
saying that I mean is there a consensus
among the economic community about
whether no deal would be catastrophic or
whether it be capable well there's two
separate things No Deal is different to
wo eto terms no deal means we leave the
European Union having signed no
withdrawal agreement so none of the
of our membership a tied-up so for
instance gentleman over there was talk
about being family in Europe if we leave
the European Union with no deal they
fall into a legal limbo because there is
no legal structure that gives them
rights there is no provision for Brits
in German law there's a provision for EU
citizens if we leave with no deal there
in a funny legal vacuum so really with
no deal we'd still have to negotiate
joining the WTO rules etc not in the WTO
but what will happen with No Deal is the
entirety the infrastructure of the laws
that govern our interactions with Europe
will cease to exist
that will be disruptive now if like the
gentleman over there your prime concern
is sovereignty and non economics then
that's a whole different debate but
there's no doubt that in the short term
at least losing those rules is going to
disrupt our economy okay right fingers
on your buzzers time let's have our
first vote of the night at using your
handsets can you answer the following
question should the UK leave the
European Union without a deal please
press 1 for yes two for no
coming up we're going to have the
results of this audience vote and also
the results of a national sky data poll
on the same question coming up in a few
moments
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to student union at Leeds
University where we're discussing some
of the thorniest issues surrounding the
UK's departure from the EU and what
solutions we could maybe come up with
away from Westminster in a moment we're
going to be introducing our next topic
for discussion but first let's bring you
the results of our audience and also the
national poll so just before the break
we asked the people here if the UK
should leave the EU with no deal and
this is what you guys said 54% of you
said yes we should leave with no deal
46% of you said no let's compare that
with the results of a much larger
national sky data poll carried out on
Friday and the results exactly the same
46%
oh sorry exactly the same but in the
other way around 46% said yes
54% said no so slightly skewed more in
favor of a No Deal here but nationally
but it is still Jolly jolly close it is
still almost 50/50 for so many people
right let's move on to our second topic
of the night
this time we're asking should the UK
delay leaving the EU to allow to either
prepare for a No Deal breaks it all
negotiate a new deal in other words
whatever happens should the whole
process be delayed I'm going to start
with Sarah over here Sarah you're an
office manager and why do you not think
we should extend why is that not a great
idea anywhere now it's just gonna be
endless properly and then need to draw
into it we need an end date where we
just say we can't sort this out we can't
come to a deal that we can all agree on
Parliament and nowhere near if I thought
they were anywhere near that I might say
yeah up another three months and see if
you can just get it that a little bit
but what Patrese mayor comes up with
tomorrow they're gonna knock back it
probably worked any good because she's
not going to have got enough concessions
to please everyone and it's just it's
just endless it we just need an endpoint
and just serve look that's it so yeah
little flatter up support for you here
and but what about the economic
consequences are you worried about that
I anticipated Roman adverted leave when
when we actually had fully bought that
the economic consequences would be more
dramatic than they have been and
probably you know you know a lot more
would have gone on very little really
seems to have happened not a great deal
that's you know we were told that with
you know would plunge back into
recession there'd be a big housing
market crash none of those things have
happened but I did anticipate some
financial sort of difficulties as a
result of Lee but and you know to me
it's worth it it's a similar picture to
what we heard anything on the other loop
tables you know at the end of the day
people will adapt and overcome that's
what they do you you know I will still
get from got to work on the 13th of
March everyone in this room will do
exactly what they were going to do
individual motivation won't change so
well they'll just carry on well let's
get a remain as point of view let's move
over here to the guys up here on the
stage Esther and you voted remain and
what do you think about the prospect of
extending it do you think that the you
know Sarah there said she just doesn't
think that the talks are going to come
to anything so there's no point do you
think there is a point well I would say
it should extend it because vote in in
the first place people didn't actually
have the fact it was just more of what
people heard and for me when I heard
about blacks it was just more about
immigration problems that was what most
people focused on so now that
information is Clara I think if you have
more time then they could come up with a
deal that is good and for me I don't
really know what the deal is if they can
actually tell us exactly what Terris
amazed Daley is probably people would
understand better and stop making
assumptions so it does a little bit of
time then in my help so more information
the more time and ignore information
Robert you're nodding next that we don't
need to have no idea we don't need for
that to happen so the European Union
wants to work with us if we turn around
and say we want to lead with No Deal
we're damaging a relationship with 27
other countries who've done nothing
wrong
they want to work with us they want for
me
that's a success thank you I think that
why alienate ourselves you know we can
work with the European Union to to
actually create a deal fair enough to be
the most deal may not be the best deal
but we have to revoke article 50 because
we are not going to be ready by the end
of March breakfast is always going to
take a long time it is not it was never
going to be a short process if we do
leave at the end of March it will still
continue it will not be over we still
have to negotiate something with the
European Union
we can't just not import your chicken
from Holland or whatever we need that
stuff so it's not going to be over and
we may as well
revoke article 50 now give us some time
to find a deal that works for everyone
because we don't have a united country
and by leaving on three nights and March
we're actually not healing the divide
well let's bring in a lever on that Josh
you're on the next table along and you
you supported leave but but you think
that but perhaps there is room for
negotiation because you you would like a
Canada style deal so I'm in favor of a
kind of plus plus plus I'm quite
disappointed that that I've been to
would be between a No Deal or threes
males deal sort of premise here however
I still think no deals better than some
use mayor's series may still because
when but the deal that we've we've got a
minute is you've got a lot uncertain
seen what what causes things like
witnessing the party needs economic
uncertainty and I think that once we
leave out the deal when we negotiate
future deals of countries they'll know
what bargaining terms are with we're
arguing with and then you can have a
more solid deals
okay that's Josh's thought well let's
just just bring you in on that Josh
mentioned Canada plus plus very briefly
basically what does that look like what
does it mean well it's what you might
call a book standard free trade
agreements there's no single market
there's no customs union everyone means
something different when they come to
the pluses the problem with Canada Plus
is it doesn't resolve Ireland
to say you'll need a special status for
Northern Ireland to avoid a border in
the Republic of Ireland but kind to say
that there's two different debates going
on one is about extending article 15th
or is about revoking and there's an
irony here we can revoke the EU doesn't
get to tell us but actually we need the
unanimous agreement of the European
Union to extend and the European Union's
attitude is not dissimilar to I think
it's Sarah was it Sarah who was saying
look they haven't agreed the European
you'll say we will extend article 50 for
a reason if you'll have a general
election you'll have a referendum but
just for your Parliament to continue not
deciding anything I don't think we're
going to get an extension for that okay
jazz we wanted to come in what did you
want to say the idea that we can leave
with no deal and that that's somehow
gonna just end the debate and we'll
never have to hear the word brexit again
is a fallacy we will have to try and get
some kind of deals in place and that
negotiation will continue this will not
be the end of it and unfortunately the
people we speak to on the streets the
leads I mean our campaign the leads for
Europe you know that there is a
misunderstanding some people think no
deal means status quo it doesn't so we
know we've got a lot of work to do as
campaign is to just say that actually
that is not what it means at all it's
not we're not just gonna remain that's
not what No Deal means I think sometimes
some of the figures and stats might be
slightly skewed by what people actually
understand No Deal to me and you know
revoke article 50 I think fantastic
because you know she's up two and a half
years as mrs. May to bring a negotiated
decent deal to the table and she's
failed to do that
how many brac six secretaries have we
had for goodness sake you know what
there's nothing in a change it would you
know she's not going to come back with
anything meaningful tomorrow that
Parliament will accept given this scale
of the defeat she had that leaves only
no deal on the table and I think it's
rather selfish to suggest that you know
might want to have our you know happy to
have your business you know disrupted
but we can we say that you know that
every person out there is happy to have
their business and their lives disrupted
pick up you know our experts look how
many people are disenfranchised
this sovereignty thing if I may just
just doesn't address that issue there
our Parliament is sovereign they have
proved that time and time again over the
past couple of weeks
they've always been sovereign the
treaties that we adhere to cannot be
amended without Parliament agreeing to
that so that there's a fallacy that we
are not sovereign we are sovereign and
actually you know the deal that we
currently have is remaining in the EU
nothing that has been presented in the
past two and a half years whether it's
Canada plus plus plus Norway plus plus
plus or whatever post to infinity we can
you know get to because that's very
seemingly heading you know we've had
some outlook absolutely nonsense spoken
by a political representatives on this
and I think David Lammy was absolutely
right when he said please can we in
Parliament stand up and be honest with
our constituents and tell them the truth
of what is going on here now you get a
black mark you mentioned a politician
not allowed not allowed I wanted to come
in very quickly about the extension
about whether we should extend who went
to Brussels it'd be Jeremy Corbyn Teresa
may the Liberal Democrats the DUP nobody
would have come back with a deal that
suited so you know would lead to any
kind of a general do they all do it
we'll just drive a bigger bigger wedge
Stephen you were waving at me just a
moment ago yes thank you
and the last woman that spoke and the
remain is on the platform and in himself
and almost the entire political class
are doing exactly the same thing they're
talking about this situation as if it's
a technical thing this is a political
situation what they've tried to do in
the two-and-a-half years since their
Democratic majority of this printed
voted to leave they can't change that
vote what they're trying to do is
discredit it to the point that they
dissolve it we live in a democracy and
that Democratic vote must be added to
okay
we're nearly out of time in this part so
let's get your buzzers ready let's have
our second vote of the night from what
you've heard this evening I think using
your handsets on your table answer the
following question should the UK delay
leaving the EU please press 1 for yes
two for no coming up we will bring you
that result and that of our national
poll stay tuned
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to the pyramid canteen
at Leeds University Union where we're
discussing some of the thorniest issues
surrounding the UK's departure from the
EU in a moment we'll introduce our next
top of the discussion but first the
results of our audience and national
poll the question was should we delay
leaving the EU now here in the studio
46% of our audience said yes 54% of
those in this room said no so that so as
this is an audience of 50/50 levers and
remain as it's interesting that they are
still favoring not extending the deal
now let's compare that with the results
of a much larger national sky data poll
which was carried out on Friday and the
result of that was exactly 50/50 so
nationally as divided as ever here in
Leeds it seems maybe it's just a
northern thing you know you think
there's just been too much talking and
not enough doing but yes you don't think
there's any point in continuing the
birther talking right let's get on to
our third topic for the night we're
asking should there be a final second
referendum the so-called people's vote
to settle this once and for all I'm
seeing lots of heads shaking so let's
have a chat with some of the people up
here on the stage and Mary
let's bring bring you in so I fall over
what impact do you think a second
referendum could have I think it could
be even more divisive than the first one
because like this gentleman over here
said during the break if the vote would
have been remained by such a slim
majority he would have accepted it and I
think you risk disengaging a large
portion of the country that took part in
this referendum that have never engaged
in politics before ever sitting next to
you sitting next to you Kerry what are
your thoughts about a second referendum
I think I agree Mary to extend and but
sometimes people say it will undermine
democratic process but I think actually
even has a democratic process but at the
moment we do have a society which is
much more fractured than any one any one
of us would like and now what we need to
is really heal those wounds and I have
absolute confidence I think we -
values and our strong economy we will
come together it's just we have to get
through this phase and we need to do it
more amicably that perhaps at the moment
we're doing with more much more divisive
and much more dissonant but you're not
whether the second referendum would be
more divisive I think but a lot of
people actually you know we do say a lot
of people voted to remain as well and so
and because we're not getting anywhere
with the current dean or perhaps he
hasn't gone to the extent as far as
people thought I would go and also a lot
of people we actually do have a lot of
people who voted to leave change their
mind and so you just don't know which
way it's gonna go but it's at least we
need to be more perhaps more informed as
to where we're going because there were
lots of there was lots of misinformation
and also lies at the time when people
were asked to vote to leave okay we'll
come back to some remainders in a moment
first I want to talk to a lever who also
thinks we should have a second
referendum that's you Johnny see so
despite winning why do you think that
second referendum would be useful I
think could be useful in in any way
because we spend such a long time
deciding the first in the first place I
don't know who told you I'd like a
second recommend that you thought maybe
a second referendum would be useful
because then it would all be over with I
think I think if we had a second
referendum I think actually it would be
the result would be remain because so
many people are sick and tired of
hearing about brexit people probably
think right well we just went through it
it'll all be over I don't think we need
a second referendum I think people make
a good choice for us a good good
argument for a second trefor and I heard
someone say you know always measure
twice cut once which is a great we spent
so much time measuring the first time if
we even if we had a second referendum
and if the vote was then remain well
which referendum should we honor best of
three
best of three exactly I mean it's it's a
complete joke people want to see
decisive action now and before there's
been too many going for it it's too much
of a mess we need to pull in the
direction of sorting this out now
and I think delaying the article 50
they're delaying the leaving it would be
absolutely no no and I think a second
referendum would be an absolute no-no as
well hold on on the same table yeah I
think a second referendum would be an
insult to democracy and also as as an
ounce said on crushing sound the other
night it wouldn't actually fix or settle
anything if you if you had another leave
result
they'd have to accept that there's
nothing they could do about it anything
else
leaves everything in the air for
instance we went into this referendum
this listen
they spent nine million pounds of
taxpayers money to send the pro romaine
leaf around the country saying this is
your decision we all enact what you
decide so we all went it into that in
good faith so that would be a massive
attack on good faith you couldn't go
into a second referendum and have a
remain vote I couldn't accept that you
know what about those who argue that
that the country hasn't changed and at
the point of a second referendum isn't
trying to different results the point is
that we've had a result and the
politicians just don't see able to sort
it out so we're at this impasse that
almost that the power needs to be taken
away from them again to sort out we've
gave them the clear instruction which is
we want to leave the European Union they
have to stop quibbling and get on with
that it's kind of like taking it you
know the parents want to go out to for a
day in the country and the kids like we
don't want to do that we voted to leave
and the political class is like oh but
we don't want to leave and all they've
done for two-and-a-half years is try and
undermine that vote and try and overturn
it you've all got your hands up and Matt
to you first of all what do you think
about the idea of a second referendum I
think this sort of narrative about
democracy sort of being in turmoil and
so you see you talked about it earlier
and about this being about democracy I
don't know why democracy ended in 2016 I
don't know
we vote on new government every five
years we we do that because the status
changes the nation changes our opinions
change and we assess the economic and
the current status and we've reassess it
and we revote on it every five years for
a general budget on after the referendum
haven't we we voted for different
political parties and the British public
the majority of British public voted for
parties that supported leaving the EU my
point being we reassess our democratic
process all the time so we surrey will
breathe oh because we the situation has
changed it's been two two and a bit
years now people's younger people who
couldn't vote at the time will now have
their voice heard they're the people
that are going to be the most affected
by well what about the the older people
who voted they're still gonna be around
don't they though and it was a very
largely a lot of the people who voted to
leave were of the older generation
they're not going to change their minds
well firstly I feel like some of them
might have changed their minds as lots
of polls been showing they're actually
people from all age ranges have been
wanting a second referendum but I think
if levers are so confident that leave is
the way forward and the people still
want it then have a second referendum
and you'll see that we'll vote leave
again but we won't because remain is
what the population wants and I had just
a quick point for you before we leave
this table yeah do you think you know
second referenda yeah I absolutely think
we travel it's like remotely the first
one well I think first of all the first
referendum the leave campaign was
completely based on immigration it was
there was fear mongering misinformation
we were told that money would go to the
NHS we know now that there's actually
four billion pounds in pace for No Deal
breaks it what about that money I think
that now people know the value of that
value of the people value free movement
trade and I think we need to give the
public another go
I'm gonna move back up to the back of
the room
and some people on this table haven't
had a chance to talk yet Becky and
you're a data analyst what do you think
about the idea of a second referendum we
were misled we weren't given the
information that we we should have had
and now people have had a chance to wake
up and smell the coffee I think the idea
of a second referendum is simply
dangerous to democracy I think everyone
knows when we voted back in 2016 we all
saw the same ballot therefore there was
an Asterix at the bottom saying two
years for two years from now you know
there's gonna be a second referendum
there was one vote and we all knew at
the time this was it this was going to
be the decision this was going to
determine whether they were going to
stay in I was they were going to come
out and I think what second referendum
supporters need to a knowledge is
there's just no way that a second
referendum could be democratically valid
because the be millions and millions of
lean for as such as myself who wouldn't
see it as valid and wouldn't participate
in it so there's just no way that could
actually be a palpable and I think the
second referendum support has just need
to acknowledge that quickly back to
Westar for more from up here I just want
to say like two gentlemen over there
kept mentioning democracy what is
democracy without facts the people
didn't know everything that was going on
but those on the other side of the
argument would say they've had it was
you as a voter to go out and find out
what it meant so but if you're looking
at you from the layman's perspective who
might not know how to do research they
don't know the facts so if you keep
capitalizing on the movements now we do
know the fact now that was false again
that's what we're saying we're not
saying to deal that it's on the table
it's that bad we don't know the facts so
if you want to vote again now we do the
ice democracy democracy is knowing
exactly what you're voting for and what
effect is going to be okay very briefly
Adam got a few seconds
people who are leaving us saying we
didn't know what was wild romaine is
saying we don't know what's gonna happen
when we leave at the same time we're
saying if we have the vote again then
it's going to be a remained vote it's an
irony that we're using one argument to
say why I remain is moaning about us
going into disarray but then we're said
we're trying to prejudge what would
happen in the second referendum there
seems to be a double oxymoron there okay
and very quickly before we do go to the
vote and a lot of speculation about
whether we could have a second
referendum how quickly could we have one
if the parliamentarians decided to if
the parliamentarians decided it will
take about 20 to 23 weeks so we need an
extension to us for it okay a good six
months okay so let's have our third boat
of the evening it's gonna take about six
months according to an and the question
is should the UK hold a second a second
and final Briggs at referendum press 1
for yes two for no
you're watching a Sky News special
program Greg's at Crisis Deal or No Deal
coming next we'll have the results of
our audience's vote and also a national
sky data poll on the same question stay
with us
[Music]
hi I'm Hannah stop with the latest
showbiz news a warning some flash
photography is coming up Hollywood star
Robert DeNiro has visited the Incan
ruins of Machu Picchu the oscar-winning
actor was honored as an illustrious
guest by the mayor of the Machu Picchu
district De Niro was reportedly
traveling with his son I'm going to son
gate next late after lunch and then I go
to my picture now
a man has been sentenced to 20 years in
prison for the fatal stabbing of actor
and Morgan Freeman's step granddaughter
in New York City
prosecutors say 33 year-old lamar
davenport stabbed his girlfriend Adina
Hines multiple times while under the
influence of alcohol and drugs in August
2015
Davenport issued an apology during his
sentencing hearing saying he doesn't
remember what happened
and at the premiere pulled the second
season of Star Trek Discovery the costs
have reflected on their childhood
memories of the beloved of franchise
they were on the red carpet for the
latest incarnation of the show in New
York it doesn't shock me because I've
had some degree of that love since I was
a little kid and watching the original
series after school watching the
original movies in the theater so that's
been a part of my experience I mean I
don't have the like deep knowledge of
every little aspect of some of the super
bands do but but it's been a part of my
consciousness in my life for that long
the gift that Gene Roddenberry gave us
was the ability to visualize a more
fulfilling and inclusive future and
that's a gift and I think that's why
people continue to come back to Star
Trek this could be the defining moment
for multiple civilizations billions of
lives the future may be determined by
our actions yours
earlier us out of the looking-glass now
are we
welcome back to Leeds where we're
discussing the same questions that are
paralyzing MPs and Westminster tomorrow
Theresa May is going to be in the House
of Commons trying to persuade MPs that
she's got a plan for brexit in a few
moments we'll be introducing our final
topic of discussion but first let's
bring you the results of our latest
audience and national poll well here we
asked the good people of Leeds should
the UK hold a second and final Briggs at
referendum here's what you guys said in
the room No 58% of you don't think we
should have a second referendum 42% of
course that means said yes here in the
room let's compare that with the results
of a much larger national sky data poll
carried out on Friday and the results
are yes
44% no 56% so it seems that that the
lack of interest in a second referendum
is echoed nationally although you are a
little bit stronger feeling here in the
room to dice right the final part of our
program and we're interested to see if
anyone has changed their mind since the
referendum in June at 2016 so in a few
minutes we're going to be asking you if
you think we were right or wrong to vote
to leave the EU and if you have changed
let's start with jazz again very briefly
jazz do you still feel the same would
you vote the same tomorrow as you voted
back in 2016 now whatever it remain last
time I vote remain again and you know as
I said before about campaigning out on
the streets of Leeds it's not just Leeds
we've been into the hardly barriers of
Barnsley Wakefield Morley Bradford you
know you name it we've been out and
about and I think the poll result you've
just showed doesn't reflect what people
are saying to us we've got we've got
evidence from people coming up and
giving us clear indications that they
would support a second referendum
people's vote and and it's about a final
say it's not about not respecting
democracy it's it's about people saying
you know what we do know more and to say
that we knew where we were going there
wasn't a single every set and nobody who
was campaigning for leave said that we
would be going out on appeal we've
covered that but earliest we'll move on
just thank you EPS down
not heard from you this evening and have
you changed your mind do still feel as
strongly that you would like to leave as
you did then absolutely I feel even
stronger today and if we don't leave now
because what we're seeing is basically a
conspiracy against democracy previously
it was covert you know the political
class would say no we respect the
referendum both labor conservatives said
they respect the referendum they didn't
want to make it a campaign issue during
the general election labour didn t want
to talk about it but since then Kirsten
was come out said I I support a second
referendum
you didn't say that during the general
election did it you know they're all
coming out and saying oh we should
really you know stay in stay in the EU
it's just obvious they're attempting to
overturn the referendum
you know the divide now is between
people who believe in democracy and the
political class who don't basically you
get a black you get a black mark for
mentioning a politician's name as well
we haven't heard from you yet and do you
feel that your views have changed on the
views of anyone you know since the
referendum
well actually I know a lot of leavers
most of my friends are leaves never I've
never I've never met one a single one
has changed - latest and I thought you'd
leave in 1975 appoint leave again and
I've completely totally and absolutely
determined to leave and I will quite to
the contrary if there's another
referendum I will be out there as that
activists have already started a
Facebook page leaders of leads to
organize people in case who isn't the
referendum and I will be campaigning to
leave what what could Theresa May do to
to help leave miss you think would work
yeah from now we would have to delete
just leave now I think it was possible I
was quite willing to listen to her along
you know to have a staged leave because
it's very very entangled to have a
staged process but she can't do that she
was in proved himself incapable of doing
that and consequently where we are now
are the only thing to do now is just
leave okay there's lots of you feel like
that and oK we've not spoken to keep in
the corner Becky and have you got any
words of wisdom for Theresa May anything
you think she could be doing that she's
not doing no I remain I would for it
remain again but I do
back to the leaf vote I feel that I
would just like to see politicians
working together I'd like to see them
stop sniping work towards a common goal
if we're well when it comes to the point
where we leave I would like the choice
between no black and no deal bracket or
a deal you're upset but yeah I would
just like to see a general consensus and
working towards a common purpose playing
nicely playing a bit nice and happy okay
we're gonna get your third your final
vote now of the evening on your on your
touch pads this is to ask you
essentially would you have you change
your mind really do you think the way
you voted do you think the country was
right to leave the EU or wrong in 2016
essentially it's breaks it a good idea
press 1 if you think it is right press 2
if you think it is wrong and we'll bring
you that results in a very short time
the interesting to see we've got 5050
one thing I was interested in in terms
of solutions this audience here we've
talked about three things tonight we've
talked about No Deal we've talked about
extending and talking more and we've
talked about second referendum if you
had to pick one I'm going to ask you a
show of hands so we'll do it on the big
camera if you have to pick one what
would it be
so could you raise your hands if you
think the best way forward now for the
government is No Deal just out well all
of the all of the leaflets okay what
about more talks more compromise
possibly some remainders okay and what
about that idea of a second referendum
that's the best idea
less support for that in the room
interesting interesting
very well done all of you right has
anyone got any advice has anyone got any
advice for a reason eh
come on come down here Stephen you've
got a lot to delay but keep it polite
apparently the nation doesn't know what
to do the political class doesn't know
what to do and I will in the buicks
you'll probably say is happy now again
about the same thing I think there's
something in this country that can unite
all of us under universal suffrage that
affects remaineth leavers
tension is all gender all classes matter
what you are it must be there in this
nation the people decide that should
unite every single person is referential
doesn't unite people in this country we
need to ask what sorts of country we're
going to have are we going to have
minority that wins and we go into a verb
and it elected own representative click
in the West Minister bubble that decides
are we going to have a panel of experts
decides that's what facing this country
and we must stick uncompromisingly to
one thing ok it must be popular
sovereignty majoritarian democracy that
should unite the entire nation ok got
any words of wisdom for the politicians
what would you like them to do alright
I'd say probably be more honest I mean
the one thing that I think probably more
more than democracy would unite us all
is that our politicians have been a
shambles over the last two years and and
then yeah I think if they could could
yeah there's lots of talk about the
national interest but there's a lot
self-interest that's gone on as well and
I think if if people could quick quick
quick put it being a bit honest with the
electorate's
about you know where they see things
that would be that'd be much brother
ok Matt I'm really hurt from you any
suggestions how I can fix it sorry
question I think the best time to
prepare for No Deal was two years ago
but the second best time to prepare for
No Deal was today
surf stories mayor is watching stop a
penguin there we go just coming back to
this table even quickly yeah I would
just say the there are various flavors
of coming out of the EU I think one of
the things I would like to see Theresa
may do is put together a cross-party
team of people to look at the various
options the Canada Post plus the Norway
plus plus coming out with no deal so
that everybody fully understands what
all the options are and that that could
once we know what these options out that
could actually put back to the people so
that they could vote sort of meaningful
by today being muted Sarah very briefly
but that gentleman's just said it's
quite a good idea but it's something
that should have been done two years ago
this is a bit like Christmas shopping on
Christmas Eve now we knew the day was
coming and everyone's running around
like headless chickens trying to sort
out they should have started two years
ago good point and meaningful votes
you've got hands up in the back I mean
do you think that'd be a useful idea I
just want to say I don't understand what
is so bad about the EU what they've done
that's so bad we are literally satya
saying leave means leave most people who
well many of my friends support leave
didn't think that actually we were going
to leave with no deal we thought we were
going to leave with some sort of deal
the EU are not working against us I
don't know why we have this mentality
that the EU is some big evil corporation
we need to unite the country resign does
anybody think she's the best person to
put your hands down
does anyone think she's the best person
to negotiate this deal going forward you
do I don't I don't think she's the best
person but she was put in that situation
and I think it I think the amount of
sexism that's taking place because she's
a woman and the fact that things like
her type 1 diabetes have been brought up
ask somebody who's worked with one of my
closest friends has that I find it's
disgusting some of the rhetoric that's
been used against her I do not agree
with the resume and many of her ideas
however had anyone else been in her
position they would have equally had the
same and the other side will say
something similar but Adam thank you
very much right we've got the results of
your vote let's bring it to you we asked
you do you think the country was right
or wrong to vote to leave the EU in 2016
and the results in the room 54% of you
think it was right that breaks it is a
good idea 45% of you think it was wrong
so pretty similar to how you felt that
you came in it doesn't look like
anyone's
minds have been changing here let's
compare that with the results of a much
larger Nat
Skai data poll carried out on Friday the
results are 49% of people think that it
was right to vote for breaks are
compared to 51% who thought it was wrong
so it's the other way around nationally
almost the reverse of the brexit vote as
well but by quite a small margin well
I'm afraid that brings us to the end of
our special program it's ruled by hasn't
had a full hour of brexit discussion
without a single MP although we did get
a couple of name checks we hope that you
enjoyed the debate and we hope that our
leaders in Westminster have perhaps take
a note of what some of these people have
been saying we heard a lot of straight
talking characteristic of this part of
the country and the votes among our
audience appear to indicate that they'd
like to get on with things and would
leave without a deal they're having none
of it when it comes to a second
referendum well thank you all very much
thank you guys for coming down here
today thank you to the pyramid canteen
at Leeds University Union for happiness
thanks for watching
Jane thanks very much indeed you're
watching Sky News do stay with us coming
up at 8:00 we'll hear more from Leeds
and Jane's political free discussion
over brexit and more on the plan be
you
[Music]
where in the world does a country go
back to their past to build their future
where can 15 centuries of art be
explored in a single day and where can
you catch your breath and have it taken
away
where do nature's hidden treasures come
to life
where can you feast your eyes in soul
under